just when I thought you couldn't look
stupider this this is quite an ensemble
you have here Merry Christmas
well why do you have nibbler on your nut
nibbler this is from Naruto no it's from
your cat yes no it's from the Kurt the
anime okay when the Domus a cartoon you
I have people on you that's why I
stopped yeah one or two goes to sleep he
has a knit cap and this is what it is
but it works is also for Christmas
Bazaar ok so this is this is the limit
and that was about as much as I could
take in that hat so it's a good title ok
so this is uh I really like this one god
this because I can really identify it
with it this is one where they they find
a maze and they have to save these hot
dog Knights who aren't very smart and
they Jake's stretching his way through
this maze and you know what my OCD is
driving me nuts like we should be
centered okay um just throw you off then
so they had Jake is stretching his way
through the maze so they can find their
way back and he gets the nights at turns
I have to get to the center of the maze
you get a wish so he's stretching all
throughout this maze and it's seeing how
far he can be Bush how far he can
stretch himself it gets to a point where
it's only like he can't close this eye
is because his eyelids would take up too
much of the skin and they get to the end
and they want to get their wish which
was Posey called the ancient psychic
tandem elephant Worrell we were saying
before I guess he said like five nights
before this V law gambling okay like
you're gonna screw it up as soon as we
get to the video ancient psychic tandem
war elephant there you go so I can't say
it at all that's why I point to him but
they get there and they he makes a wish
for it he controls the war elephant the
world elephant makes a wish for Finn for
everyone to get better and they fly off
and it just stops like there's a ghost
where there was a what do we learn today
is the
I said not that you need it it's kind of
obvious but at the same time it's like
it just stopped so quickly it wasn't
even like a joke or anything it makes it
a little funny or actually not having a
joke
so yeah I I like this one because even
though I guess there's a little bit of a
villain at the end the guy in the you
know any mud snake yeah and the you know
whatever different creatures try again
and stuff like that there's like the hot
dog Knights keep you know egging him on
but I mean it's they're not bad guys
they're just not very smart
and I think this episode is good because
I think this is something a lot of
people fall into you know when to get
text in the middle of e-logs
no max what technican in the middle of a
walks Vee logs it sounded like you just
said II one sec so I might say things a
little too straight to shut up you know
that's gonna be your wife
I wanna say you said that she never
watches these just go to this part in
the view log that's what's doc who said
that um so but yeah it's I like this
idea that's cuz a lot of stories it's
when someone's being pushed to the limit
it's by a villain or bag or II that has
to be done or something and here's
something where they could turn around
they could go away and it's just the
attraction of not wanting to let
somebody down and just being pushed to
the limit as the title says and I think
everybody at some point does kind of hit
that where it's it's not that someone's
working them too hard it's that they
themselves think they can do more than
they can or they make a promise they
can't fulfill or it's just killing them
following through you know that it can
really really wear you down and just
push you beyond that so I know I
definitely had that last year last year
I did like something like 13 cons I had
my wedding and I moved and we did the
4th year anniversary it's just it was
insane I finally said ok I gotta cut
this in half and even this year still
was too much you should have seen him
off the camera he was kind of losing his
mind a bit yeah as opposed to on camera
one
totally normal saying don't interrupt my
Ewoks but
we're both kind of sick like I said so
we might just go insane at times cuz
like we have a sickness where it's like
you're okay and then you'll just crash
then you're okay and then you'll crash
so yeah we might just it's my show now
get off me oh man oh no oh no he's
touching me
well I want to talk about the show while
he apparently strokes me so what
actually I really liked about it was
that it was the hot dog Knights cheering
him on and Jake said himself all you to
say my name three times and I'll pretty
much do anything and that's the extent
of it was that these hot dog nights for
the ones that just kept saying go go go
and throughout Finn was like no you need
to stop what you're doing and why are
you massaging my ear okay sorry
what'd I miss you see you massaging my
ear no really what happens kind of nice
no don't do that oh sorry
you look like shake like is slowly
exploding a human but then you gotta
take it thin you could put him here and
it's like finding writing tape I think
you just found your halloween costume is
like the cheapest halloween cashmere but
it could work so um no I like the fact
that throughout finish consistently
telling Jake you need to stop we need to
go back just knock it off and Jake's
like no no I could totally do this and
the dumb ass hot dog Knights Jake Jake
Jake I can do anything
mm-hmm and well and when it gets to the
end where he's like really I mean it's
both really funny and really hard to
watch just this tiny Jake that's like I
think this is heroic Finn's holding this
little a just looks like a bit of string
but these are strings hanging off there
is our and it's it's both really funny
but you're also going go for Jake you
know you feel really bad for him um or
or when the eyelids couldn't yeah in his
eyes Gabi you feel legitimately bad but
it's also so funny and what do you think
of the part where you know they get to
the end and they have to go a little
further to reach the
you know the area to wish and he says
and fin finally said you know okay check
it carry us over you can do it you can
do what do you think of that cuz i guess
i guess it levels out okay cuz their cat
trap there he says i can't be pushed
even a little bit more but i don't know
it was sort of like you could turn back
you can do whatever and he i know you
had to be pushed even more infinite but
even though does that go against the
message i don't think it does because
the door is closed it's not just that i
mean I think also Finn realized and
thought about it okay when we get over
there I wish for you to be better and
you wish for the elephant yeah I mean I
think cuz that's what he said I'm gonna
wish for you to get better that yeah I
just no matter what like you view it
even if he dies on the way over it could
be like you know I wish for you to come
back a line room yes I mean yeah and I
think that was kind of the intent was
it's like you know what we're kind of
trapped here cuz without Jake stretchy
ability they couldn't just go over the
wall and you know they'd have they were
kind of stuck so I said go go go and I
love the reason just you know don't
cheat or you'll die just yeah okay so
you have no idea what that could just be
a sign that says that and they'd only
notice it's all like math and everything
and then it morphs into that mmm which I
thought was pretty neat I'm like oh yeah
that's right the Scorpion part but where
he's holding up he's holding all the
scorpions and it's like oh you just have
to worry about the little ones or is
that snakes oh wait there it is kids
poisons kicking in this is definitely an
episode I think because Jake goes
through so little abuse because of what
he is or what he can do and this one you
really I mean like when they're stinging
him and everything you're really like
dude Jay you felt like uh-oh what was
that one episode oppas lost days did you
ever watch Avatar no yeah there's an
episode like playing yeah there's this
episode nothing but him just like
getting on and beaten and stuff
like that it's like really you know what
you weirdo it's fun um but you get my
little op adult I have it home now I
just take a nice slam I'm like Daisy
Papa I guess I'm a little sick in every
meaning of that word now oh you're
you're hurting fan mouth no he's
fighting for me oh he fights weird
dude do the arm thing raise like yeah
good though they do like that god I'm
sick okay so yes so I like because you
see you know I cared to be pushed to its
limit without necessarily a bad guy it's
someone who's pushing themselves for no
real reason I mean so you could say
appreciation what everybody he doesn't
know these guys he's pushing himself for
a bunch of idiots yeah I mean he he's
doing it I don't even say for approval
he's doing it just to be nice you know
just to like you know oh yeah I can do
that and it's there's always this part
of you that thinks you can go further
and further and further
oh just a little bit more just a little
bit more at some point you know you're
gonna get the straw that breaks the
camel's back though I don't think it was
because he was being nice like I said
almost just like I don't know Jory
helped me out really quick it feels nice
when people think you're cool and great
and you want to keep that up yeah jari
axis says her I think it's more like he
wants to impress he wants to show these
people yeah I totally can do this I am
awesome okay so that you think it is a
Bevin ego I think it I think it
definitely comes down to a bit of an ego
thing because if you notice just like
yeah I think I should turn back
come on you're awesome you can do it
it's like yeah I guess I can say my name
three times I'll do it like I didn't see
it as a I'm doing it man yes I mean I do
we can have a different no no no I I
think it is I mean it is just my own way
I see it more like he just he just wants
to be nice they like saving people's day
you know they like doing genuinely nice
things and they're just overly positive
people too so it's like I can I can kind
of see just like you know oh okay I can
do a little bit more but at the same
time and that is kind of true he does
like to you know always push himself to
the extreme and yeah just like big grand
adventures and you know anything it's
like the maximum anything he wants to do
so that's interesting since a few was at
home and that was what you think what's
he doing to be nicer do you think it was
ego yeah because I think it's actually
pretty good the big is either could
really work but yeah any final words on
this one no I liked it
okay stay away from me you weirdo
got it for Christmas you're coughin you
I'm already sick so it won't really
matter damn good coffin Joey and my
kissing you tonight
sneaking up today's our anniversary
that's right it's our anniversary
oh no kind of ha ha